Avez-vous soif de culture , d'anecdotes croustillantes !?
Comme tes frites à la cantine le mardi entre deux heures de français
Oui, mes comparaisons sont de plus en plus longues et c'est super chiant
Les amis, on est sur "Vrai ou Faux 2"
Le design a progressé, j'espère que les anecdotes aussi
C'est parti, on commence
Les mots de passe les plus utilisés en 2016 sont :
"123456" , "123456789" et "QWERTY"
Ouais, c'est sûr
Chaque année la liste des mots de passe utilisés ne change pas
Mettez des mots de passe plus sécurisés, voyons
On appelle un paon fou une cacahuète
Mais c'est totalement faux
C'est quoi ce délire ? "Bien évidemment"
Bah attends, on est là pour euh... HEIN !
On veut des vrais anecdotes, nous
Hodor est le nom du dieu norvégien de l'hiver
Bon, dans Game of Thrones, "Hodor", c'est un mec qui empêche aux portes de s'ouvrir
Mais, à part ça...
C'est un gars qui vient du Nord
Et c'est la seule info que j'ai sur lui
Du coup c'est peut-être vraiment le nom du roi norvégien du Nord
Allez, on dit vrai
Anecdote de ouf
YESSS ! C'est ouf !
Shakespeare portait des boucles d'oreilles
Ah ça c'est tendu, ça ! J'ai vraiment 0 lianes à laquelle m'accrocher pour essayer de deviner
On va invoquer le doigt de la chance
J'ai envie d'y croire
OOOOOOOOOh ! OUII !
Il est incroyable
À l'époque, porter des boucles d'oreilles était emblématique pour la poésie
P****** mais ça, c'est ça que j'aime, apprendre des choses et les ressortir dans 10 ans
en me la pétant
P****** je le savais !
Oh la p*******, j'aurais jamais dû faire chair-flip, la dernière fois
Je manque de me péter la gueule maintenant
Harry-Potter était le livre le plus banni des États-Unis en 2001 et 2002
Pourquoi banni ? Attends, soit ma traduction est pétée, soit je comprends pas l'anecdote, là
Bon je dirais vrai, parce que c'est "wahou"
D'accord, donc c'est vraiment banni des librairies par ce que c'était un livre anti-famile, occulte et satanism
qui apportait un point de vue sur la religion et qui était violent
WHAT THE FUCK ?!
Et c'est le livre le plus vendu de tous les temps mec, AHAH !
Et attention comme je suis très fort, j'enchaîne sur une autre anecdote à l'heure actuelle, Harry Potter après des livres religieux genre le Coran, la Bible et des livres de citations
c'est le livre le plus vendu au monde
C'EST OUF !
La durée de vie d'un écureuil est d'environ 20 ans
C'est assez petit, donc je dirais vrai
OH NAN, C'EST FAUX !
ça vit en moyenne 9 ans
OK, OK...
Tous les ours polaires sont irlandais
AAAAAAH, c'est peut-être vrai ça, mec
Ouais, ouais, ils descendent des ours bruns qui vivaient en Irlande il y a plus de 25.000 ans
c'est tous des p******* d'Irlandais, p*******
La Chine a banni le voyage dans le temps à la télé
Mec, ça m'étonnerais pas, je suis sûr qu'il y a moyen. Pour une raison un peu con, comme les mêmes raisons que Harry Potter qui a été banni dans les années 2001-2002
Je pense que oui
C'est vrai, mec
OH ! C'est vrai, c'est génial !
Les dramas avec du voyage dans le temps sont très populaires en Chine donc la Chine a bloqué tous les films qui parlaient de voyages dans le temps
en disant que ça manque de respect à l'Histoire
Ah, donc le peuple kiffe un truc, on le supprime et on trouve un prétexte pété, d'accord
je vois pas en quoi ça manque de respect à l'Histoire, au contraire je trouve ça marrant de, effectivement, modifier un seul élement de l'Histoire et de voir toutes les conséquences que ça pourrait avoir
sur tout le reste,
voir que le monde d'aujourd'hui ne serait pas du tout pareil, par exemple
"La La Land" a battu le record du film qui a reçu le plus de Golden Globe
Ouais, ça me parait vrai, c'est vrai !
Il a gagné tous les Golden Globe dans lesquels il était nominé
Et on ne l'a pas vu !
Vous l'avez vu ?
Il y a plus de gens qui vivent à Tokyo qu'il n'y a de gens dans tout le Canada
Mec, Tokyo c'est énorme, je crois que c'est 4-5 fois Paris, attends
Je viens de regarder, il y a 6 fois plus d'habitants à Tokyo que à Paris, mec
Je pense que c'est vrai
OH ! C'EST VRAI !
Tokyo possède plus d'habitants que la majorité des pays
12 millions d'habitants dans 23 arrondissements !
Et juste l'arrondissement Setagaya fait la même taille que tout Paris
C'est incroyable ce qu'il se passe
J'espère ne pas être le seul à m'exclamer de la sorte
Au quel cas, j'aurais l'air bien con
Les cochons sont les seuls animaux avec les humains qui peuvent attraper des coups de soleil
Attends, les anecdotes elles sont 1000 fois mieux que dans le 1, mon gars
Je suis totalement en train de kiffer
Bah, ça n'a pas de pelage comme par exemple un singe ou un chat ou un félin, je dirais que c'est vrai
C'est faux ! C'est faux....
Beaucoup d'animaux peuvent avoir un coup de soleil
Ah, c'est vraiment très faux
Sous certaines conditions, même les poissons peuvent en avoir
AHAHAH !
En plus ils sont dans l'eau, ils prennent trop cher avec les reflets et tout...
Ah c'est marrant, ça ! Je ne savais pas
Vous saviez pas hein ? Ah, on apprend des trucs, c'est incroyable, Squeezie apprend des choses c'est fou !
En 1991, les gorilles étaient entraînés à utiliser des téléphones par les brésiliens
C'est vrai, c'est tellement nul que c'est vrai !
AH C'EST FAUX ! AH MERDE ON M'A TELLEMENT DIT UN TRUC DE OUF, moi p*******
Ah, je passe pour un gros teubé
L'Inde possède 122 langages majeurs
C'est vrai, c'est tellement un pays énorme
Et 1599 autres langues ?!
Incroyable
Il y a 1000 ans dans une année lumière
PPPPFFFFFFFFFFFF ! Totalement faux !
TOTALEMENT FAUX ! AH !
J'avais fait l'erreur dans une vidéo alors que je savais déjà la réponse, c'est une unité de distance et pas de temps
Bah voilà, c'est exactement ce qu'ils disent
Après on sait pas, peut-être que j'ai lu ça avant de vous dire ma réponse, on sait pas, on est pas à l'abri d'un mitomane
L'année 2016 fut l'année avec les températures enregistrées les plus chaudes
C'est vrai ?
C'est vrai.
C'est chaud, hein
L'Empire Romain était le plus grand empire de l'Histoire
C'EST VRAI !!
C'EST FAUX !!
C'est le 28ème !
Oh, comment je ferme bien ma gueule, ça ça m'a bien fait redescendre sur terre
On devrait tous jouer à ça une fois par semaine pour *siffle* redescendre
Les moustiques sont plus attirés par les couleurs claires
C'EST FAUX ! Ils sont aveugles et se repèrent avec des odeurs !
Les moustiques sont en fait attirés par des couleurs sombres, parce que les couleurs sombres leurs servent de protection
Bon, voilà, j'avais raison à hauteur de 1%
Le bonhomme de neige le plus grand du monde faisait 37 mètres !
Vas-y c'est vrai, c'est sûr y a des gens qui ont fait un truc aussi grand
Voilà c'est un mec aux USA qui a fait le plus grand bonhomme de neige du monde
La plus grosse somme d'argent dépensée pour obtenir une vache aux enchères est de 200 000 $
C'est faux, c'est plus haut je suis sûr
OH OUI, c'est ça  *rigole*
C'est 1,3 millions de dollards
Qu'est-ce qu'elle avait la vache ? Comment une vache peut avoir autant de valeur ?
Enfin, par rapport à une autre ? C'est bizarre
Le cafard est l'animal à 6 jambes le plus rapide
C'est vrai je crois. Je crois que ça court super vite, cette merde
C'est vrai, quand il est en danger il peut parcourir 1 mètre en juste 1 seconde
Ouais, je savais que ça courait vite ces p******* de merdes, là
En plus d'être répugnant, extrêmement répugnant !
Les algorithmes de reconnaissance faciale utilisé par Facebook sont plus performantes que ceux utilisés par le FBI
Vas-y, j'ai envie d'y croire !
J'ai envie d'y croire
C'EST VRAI !!!
"C'est pas choquant du tout"
Mais bien sûr que si !
WHAT THE FUCK ?!
Les chercheurs ont construit une intelligence artificielle qui est chargée d'apprendre à construire un logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
AHAH ! Je suis sûr c'est vrai
AH OUAIS C'EST VRAI, P******* !
... qui lui même est chargé d'apprendre à créer un logiciel d'intelligence artificielle, qui lui même est chargé....
Hé mec, c'est pas con du tout comme ça tu as une infinité de euh... enfin bref...
Moi, je suis chercheur dans l'âme, je suis chercheur de pièces d'or sur World of Warcraft, c'est tout
Ll'alcool et le vin sont illégaux aux US sauf s'ils sont radioactifs
Nan, mais n'importe quoi il y en a partout
Nan, mais arrête, n'importe quoi là, le créateur il ne savait plus quoi faire
Hé, je suis sûr il a copié toutes ces anecdotes sur un site qui s'appelle anecdotescool.com
Il est arrivé au bout, et là il a créé les trucs lui-même et c'est parti en c*******
Il y a une chauve-souris qui suce le sang humain
AH J'AI ENVIE D'Y CROIRE !
OH P********
Au Brésil, la chauve-souris diphylla ecaudata... Attends, on dirait carrément une escouade de chauve-souris, quoi
Ouais escouade "eco", on est prêt à le sucer
Ouais ici "data", ah mais nan c'est "delta"
ça marche pas cette vanne
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH !!!!
Je vous ai fait perdre votre temps là, oh merde vite c'est la dernière anecdote, on arrête.
Elle a commencé à sucer le sang des humains
P****** c'est chaud, une sorte de moustique IMMENSE qui n'a rien à voir avec un moustique
AAAAH, c'est le moment de terminer cette vidéo
Eh bah voilà les amis, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo, je commence à fatiguer
Mon cerveau a ingurgité beaucoup d'infos, il faut que je dorme pour qu'il classe bien toutes ces infos,
à des endroits qui font que je ne m'en souviendrai plus dès demain
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu et si vous aimez les anecdotes comme ça... Moi je suis un grand curieux
J'adore les anecdotes comme ça, mais un peu plus scientifiques
Allez, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien, j'espère que ça vous a fait kiffer
d'apprendre des trucs surtout que franchement les premières anecdotes elles étaient assez folles
Allez, portez-vous bien, à très bientôt pour de prochaines vidéo, ciao tout le monde !
*blanc*
Peace
*musique de fin*